Hello everyone and please join
me in welcoming us if Sally
awesome.
As a senior director of strategy,
communications and empowerment for BRAC
and BRAC international here receives the
advocacy information and communication
technology and communications departments
as well as social innovation lab.
He also manages bracs
empowerment initiatives
including human rights and legal
aid services,
migration,
urban and use skills development programs.
Prior to joining Brac in 2011 he was the
executive director at Goldman Sachs and
previously worked for IBM.
He was recognized for his work by
Asia Society's Asia 21 program,
the Bango that she American foundation
and it was selected as an Asia 21 fellow
awesome connects private and social
sectors to develop and scale innovations
that uplift some of the
world's poorest people.
A bit of context on Brac brack is the
world's largest nonprofit organization and
is based in Bangladesh.
It's a global leader in developing and
implementing cost effective evidence
based programs to assist more marginalized
people and extremely poor conflict
prone and post disaster settings.
These include initiatives in
education, healthcare, micro finance,
girls' empowerment, agriculture,
human and legal rights, and more.
In 2016,
brack employed more than 110,000
people in 11 countries with a global
expenditure of about 900 million.
With low middle income countries
like Bangladesh develop,
developing very rapidly,
both high and low tech solutions will be
instrumental in bridging group growing
socio economic divide as
it provides insight on how
Brac we'll reach 130 million
people and changing the way poverty
is addressed worldwide. Thank you.
Please take the floor.
Okay.
Let me start off talking about a little
bit about myself. Uh, just to give up,
give up personal context.
I grew up in Bangladesh and
that when I was 18, I left, uh,
to get my higher education
in the United States.
So I got a degree in computer
science. Um, and uh, when I graduated,
what I wanted to do with my life was
more about solving business problems.
Then I graduated at the time when there
was tech jobs were quite plentiful.
And, um, I,
I landed with four offers
before I finished my graduation
and I decided to take
up a job at Goldman Sachs. And, uh, um,
my motivation was that I didn't want to
be a programmer who was just coding at
the back bench,
just nobody looks at him.
I actually want it to be what I
work with people and solve problems.
And before I knew it,
I spent almost a 12
years at Goldman and um,
but,
uh,
working with trading and electronic
trading algorithms and all these things,
but something was not
quite right. And, um, this,
I felt like this was not quite
about what I was meant to do,
probably not the kind of problems I wanted
to solve with for the rest of my life.
So I started a charity back
in 2001 and my free time, uh,
which was a platform for diaspora
Bangladeshis to connect and also work on a
cause for human rights, uh,
victims in Bangladesh. And a,
the idea was that to raise awareness,
uh,
on human rights issues and
also to rehabilitate them
and glad to see there is a
fellow member here as [inaudible] who
was here, who was a member of this.
And I connected with a lot of young
Bangladeshis during that time.
And the organization actually,
uh, grew quite rapidly. Um,
before I knew it,
we had like nine chapters in nine
cities and we were connected, uh,
all around the world and we were doing
projects and we had 5,000 people in our
network. Uh, so, and that was my thing. I,
I figured that this is something
that I was prone to do. And,
uh, so I, I had to take a leap of faith.
I had to decide what I wanted to do
that with the rest of my life. So, um,
at one point I decided to end my career
at Goldman and moved back to Bangladesh
and, um, started to work
in the development sector.
And then that's where they were kind
of the rest of my life started. So I,
um, I actually from the number
one investment bank, uh,
I joined the number one NGO, which
is the Brac. So quite a, quite a,
quite a large shift.
But interestingly,
from what to add to what
Sylvia said about Brag, uh,
I think when I joined Bragg,
it was a quite an interesting learning
because a Brac is something so unique
that uh,
there isn't a lot of charity
organizations like Brag because um,
I'm Brad kind of users,
whatever works to solve
a development problems.
So whether it's a business is, it's a
market based solutions, I think it's,
it's fairly agnostic to what
kind of solution would work.
And that resulted to brag from being a
very small relief organizations to what a
giant bay mode that is right now,
which has very,
very large scale programs in
education law running the largest,
a non government school network to one
of the largest microfinance network to a
very big health networks
all around the country.
And it expanded outside Bangladesh
about 12 years ago now it's in 12 other
countries. So as you heard that, you
know, it's a total budget in global,
but it is about one point $1 billion with
about 70% of Bangladeshis budget comes
from its own resources.
And we are slowly towards a,
are on a path to become self dependent
for our Bangladesh programs in the next
five to seven years. So, um,
but what a Brac has is that,
you know,
it's quite unique in the sense that it
has these large scale programs that I
mentioned.
It also has about 15 social enterprises.
It has about seven large
investments that it made, um,
from a bank to insurance companies to um,
various, uh, uh, other at a
university is, it's, it's,
it's a quite unique, but there is
a kind of a method to all this,
uh, large expansion. And
in order to get to that,
I think I should talk about
a quote that our founder,
surface foster has an APP.
It talks about a lot of time,
which is a poverty is not just
poverty of money or income.
We also see a poverty of self esteem,
hope, opportunity and freedom.
People trapped in a cycle of destitution
often don't realize their lives can be
changed for the better
through their own activities.
Once they understand that,
it's like a light gets turned on.
So at Brac we are in the business of
turning those lights on. So where there,
it's about financial inclusion
or education or any of
our livelihood's program,
it's all about turning that light on,
giving people the tool so that
they can change their lives.
So today I'm going to
tell you two stories,
uh, 30 years apart, uh,
about two of the biggest challenges
we've faced and what we learned about the
role of technology and social
innovation in those challenges. Um,
so first case story is about a fairly
low tech solution with a high touch
approach.
Um,
imagine you are an illiterate mother.
back in the early eighties in Bangladesh,
in the rural Bangladesh,
you live in an extremely remote region.
Uh,
the country's still reeling economy
Lee from the war that happened about 10
years ago.
But this isn't your biggest concern.
Your concern is about your sexual sec
child was suffering from diarrhea and uh,
your thoughts are consumed with her
because you don't know what to do.
The nearest hospital is about five miles.
You don't have the money to
take your child to the hospital.
You don't have access to
any physician a nearby.
So what do you do in that situation?
Um,
particularly when you know that about one
out of five children in your community
dies in a suffering from
diarrhea. Um, diarrhea,
dehydration that caused from diarrhea
and cholera was one of the primary
killers, uh, of child under
five, uh, in, in Bangladesh.
A about one out of seven children in
Bangladesh in the right after a war would
actually won't make it
to their fifth birthday.
So when that's the
scenario you're working on,
actually this kind of related of
why we had so many children a,
each household had so many children in
there because if you don't know how many
would survive, you actually don't think
about family planning that much. Uh,
actually recently there was a code
by Melinda Gates the other day who
highlighted that if parents believe their
children will survive and if they have
the power to time and space
their pregnancies, they chew,
they would choose to have fewer children.
So parents living in poverty in rural
Bangladesh didn't have control of what
their children's lives or,
or their futures.
So it wasn't that there wasn't
a solution, uh, available.
There was actually in the 60s,
there was a breakthrough in
treatment for diarrhea, right?
A concoction of water sugar and
salt called oral rehydration therapy or
OT was tested by a group of researchers.
However, um, this, this
concoction that you, if you give,
given to the children at the right time,
it would actually save 96.5% of the
children as opposed to 70% who would not
make it.
But the problem there was another problem
with the treatment was out of reach
for poor families and remained
mostly in the hospitals because, uh,
one, uh, you have to get
the proportion right.
The researchers did have the idea that,
um,
that at some point they will,
marketed and they will make the
instruction available for people.
But when you have illiterate
mothers all around the country,
that instruction is actually not
very useful when you have, um,
instructions about giving spoons
and measurements, right. When you,
most of the households don't have
even spoons doesn't really work.
So what, uh, what do you do
in that kind of situation?
Because if you don't get the measurement
right, if you have too much salt,
it may kill your baby.
If you have too much sugar,
it may actually reverse the effect
of the Ortiz what is aligned.
So that's where the,
I guess the power of delivery
comes in around that time. Uh,
so brack was about 10 years old and um,
there was a guy called surface that
has an abbot who moved back from London
living his cushy job at Shell oil and uh,
and decided that he was going to
actually work towards rebuilding the,
rebuilding the country
after the war. And, uh,
pretty soon the relief organization
actually slowly expanded or,
um, into other, other
development activities. And, um,
he was from the private sector and he
understood scale very well and he was all
about problem solving.
So when he heard about the problem,
one of the things that he tried,
but he was started experimenting in
this kitchen with unrefined sugar,
known as good in Bangladesh,
which is fairly well available
in rural areas, rural areas.
So he found out that about
three finger pinch of salt,
a handful of sugar, um, good. Um,
and half a liter of boiled water
actually can make the same,
have the same effect that this World
Health Organization that came up with the
antidote for the RT solution.
So,
so that's how the easy to
make solution arrived. Um,
but then how do you actually teach
it to the rest of the country?
How do you actually go to mothers and
tell them that this is actually going to
work and this is what you should do?
So that's where the
biggest challenge came in.
And the, and World Bank's
president recently said, uh,
at a code that it's not the question
of what to deliver. It's about,
it's about how to deliver it in the,
when in the social development space.
It's all about, not the, not
the digital innovation itself,
but how do you actually
deliver the innovation.
So our media advocacy campaign
would have worked at that time.
I wouldn't have worked at
that time because only 20%
people have access to radio
and television. So it would have
to be centered on the ground,
people talking to people,
people changing behaviors.
So that's what Brac started to do.
So it recruited that small groups of
women from communities to become health
promoters themselves.
The group traveled on foot,
um, went door to door, showing
mothers how to make these solutions.
Later monitors went in and checked
whether how many of those mothers actually
learned how to make those solutions.
And it was an iterative process.
There was failures and plentiful we
learned as we go along. Went along,
so stuff to it, their approach as
they went along. And, and one thing,
I'm sorry, just to, and, and,
and one example of our learning has been
that when the monitors went back after
the first lot of training happen,
we found out that about 90% of this
mothers learn how to make those solutions.
So you would think that was a success,
but only 10% of them actually gave it
to their children when the children were
sick. So people were struck scratching
their heads what went wrong.
A group of anthropologists were sent to
do some research and they found out was
very interesting, uh, not rocket
science, but because the mothers,
the fathers weren't involved in this
process and they were the key decision
makers.
So they actually wouldn't let the mothers
give this strange concoction to their
child when they got sick.
So that's when the next battle started.
So we started training men, we
started training the fathers. So,
and this is just an example,
but there are other issues evolve.
The process was continuously modified and
which led to continuous improvement of
the outcome itself.
So Brag,
then worked with the Bangladeshi
government of course, uh,
to kind of scale up nationwide.
Uh,
it basically eventually went to every
single household in Bangladesh teaching
mothers how to make ort and um,
that's um,
uh, media advocacy campaign followed
to sustain the effect. Uh, eventually.
And just to kind of finish off
the story, um, I mean there, uh,
there was a long article
on this in New York,
New Yorker magazine a couple of years ago.
I'm just going to read a few coats,
um,
coaxing villagers to make the solution
with their own hands and explain the
messages in their own words while a
trainer observed and guided them at youth
far more than any public service ad or
instructional video could have done.
Over time the changes could be sustained
with television and radio and the
growth of demand led to the development
of a robust market for manufacturer oral
rehydration salts three decades led later.
National surveys have found that almost
90% of children with severe diarrhea
where given the solution child deaths
from diarrhea plummeted more than 80%
between 1980 and 2005.
Bangladesh.
Now has the highest use
of working in the world.
So this is the quote I love and it's,
I think it's relevant to a lot of
a lot of you who are in technology.
I mean we yearn for frictionless
technology solutions,
but people talking to people is still
the way norms and standards change.
Um, so there were some
early lessons in this, uh,
kind of just to kind of quickly summarize.
Um,
even in 30 years ago, I know data
is big now, but even 30 years ago,
data was king then at that time as well.
We constantly looked
at the numbers and uh,
evolved number two,
social innovation is not just
about a product innovation,
it's about a continuous process of
adjustment and tweaking as you go along.
It's about process innovation as well.
And number three,
the simpler your solution is,
the easier it is to scale.
So it's very, very relevant to that.
Uh, the part of the world we operate in.
So fast forward about 30 years later.
Uh,
so this is the second case story I'm
going to talk about. Uh, which was,
is more about when high
tech meets high touch.
Um, how do you get rural
women and men of course,
to trust and understand that mobile
money will improve their lives. Um,
just to set a set a context and there's a,
there's a story that, uh, you know,
our microfinance director, uh,
talks about that when we
introduced a mobile money to,
for our microfinance borrowers
to pay their loans on time. Um,
they would send the money mobile money
through their phone and then they would
walk to our offices and come back,
come and say that makes sure that
it actually has come through. And,
um, because I think
that's, that's, you know,
in a country where system often fails,
you always want that piece of paper with
a to make sure that this is your proof
that you actually have done it.
You don't actually have trust,
a lot of trust in your system. So it, it,
it was actually quite interesting because
it do have them trust an SMS message
I've confirmation was
actually quite a large shift.
So,
um,
the idea idea for mobile money
came in from a different context.
I mean, I think, uh, when 30
years they didn't like, you know,
in Bangladesh has become
a lot more urbanized,
is not as real anymore. Uh, also
people have become a lot more mobile.
They're traveling,
they're seasonal migrants who are coming
back and forth from villages to cities.
They're working in the cities and
they're wanting to send their money as in
money to their families.
So there was a big need of a safe,
reliable,
and affordable means of sending
money back home. Of course,
people found very creative way of sending
money. They send it through the bus,
overnight bus service.
They would send the money through post
office air through the selling airtime or
physically carrying cash
form every human's. Uh,
but there was a big need of some something
which actually did it quickly and
reliably. So that's where the solution
came in, which is the big cash,
the mobile financial service.
Um,
inspired by the success in
east Africa with M Pesa. Um,
and some of the other companies
that work really well in Africa,
Brac bank started a be cash in 2011 with
the mission towards including the very
bottom of the people on financially,
which means that actually
not only just residents,
but the big vision is that introducing
financial products and services that
works for the poor. So, um, it,
it was a great fit for Bangladesh
because in Bangladesh we have 90% of the
household which has mobile phone,
but only 30% has bank accounts.
So if you can give people
with a phone bank account,
it should work wonders. Um, but
the problem was, I mean, just to,
of,
so before I get into the problem a bit,
just to give you an understanding
of how the solution worked. Um,
it's not just a mobile to mobile money.
It's a,
there's a role of an agent
network within the organization.
The idea is that a rickshaw
puller say who works in the city,
wants to send money to his family,
would actually go to an agent who
would actually take the physical cash,
put it in his bank account, uh, mobile.
And mobile money account and then the
have the money transferred to either
directly to the,
to the family or to an agent
whose lives nearby, uh, to the,
of the family member. And then
the family could use it. I mean,
if the money was transferred to
the bank account of the sender,
they could also use it for other
purposes as well, like, you know,
buying things directly. But we don't see,
we don't have the ecosystem yet quite,
quite ready. So one is mostly
being used for reference purposes.
So this is how it works.
Um,
but the problem was that then it
also went to 100 the delivery.
Everybody, nobody knew be cash,
right? Why would people trust be cash?
But everybody knew Brac
at that time and brags.
This is just our sort of operations
in terms of where we are,
um,
in terms of in the country itself.
So we have a network
all across the country.
So what we started to build up with this
agent network and we worked with all
these borrowers that we have
who actually owns stores.
So there are these small shop owners
who we went to and says that, you know,
you know, the community community knows
you. Are you interested to be an agent?
And, uh, initially there was
like, not a lot of understanding,
but people came along listening to us
because we thought we said this is going
to work for you and this is gonna work
for everybody else in the community as
well.
So,
but 10,000 agents signed up initially
and once we did it and that's where the
early adopters came in and then we
started working with the use user,
growing the user base,
you're going forward.
And the rest is pretty much
history because I mean,
because she has seen a very, very rapid
expansion over the last five years.
Just to show you some numbers. I
mean, this is a slightly dated number,
but we now have, uh, it is now the largest
mobile financial service in terms of,
uh, how many people have a direct accounts
in the world right now where we have,
uh, about, uh,
close to in Bangladesh we have about 400
and so 41 million people with accounts
and about 80% of them are
big cash account holders. Uh,
you can see some of the numbers.
We, uh, the rapid growth,
I mean we have almost close to about
$50 million being transacted daily.
Um, and, um,
now the agent network boasts about
600,000 or around the country.
Um, just in, it all just
happened in just four years.
But I mean, we don't want to, we didn't
want to rest in this Laurel. However,
I mean,
because as I,
as I said that the primary mission was
to actually empower the poor financially.
So we looked at the numbers again and we
saw that there were far less women who
signed up than men for
the big cash accounts.
And at the same time people were still
accessing it primarily as through the
agent network,
not directly accessing themselves ran.
If you don't access it directly yourself,
then financial products and
services built up for you,
you're not going to actually
see a lot of benefit for it.
So I'm going to see a small video in terms
of how we took that as a next step in
terms of increasing
the literacy for women.
And this will probably give you
a bit of a glimpse, uh, of, uh,
what we mean by this
high touch involvement.
Let's look at a two
minute video very quickly.
Hm.
Goodbye.
Like
Daca,
Daca
baggage with put them,
if they do end up with them,
she's
[inaudible]
she, she goes, you cannot
put a segment on Dixie money
leaves it at Bella
[inaudible].
I'm rolling shutter stock.
Oh,
by the banker.
[inaudible] and [inaudible]
I guess the DDC transfer,
the DC. Marsha, Marsha
[inaudible].
I seem to literacy biggest [inaudible]
right, okay. The dietitian
isn't montage. Tronic PC,
PC.
I'm a good data.
So the work is still
ongoing. I mean it's, uh,
I think the user experience needs to be
a lot better. So we are working on that.
Uh, but I think this, uh, there are
some key learnings, right? I mean,
in both these two stories.
Uh,
so I think in,
in person to person interaction does
shift social norms and builds trust.
And for, for a lot of technology
adoption, adoption, um,
um, it's not just about
technology itself, right?
It's about changing
mindsets. So it's, it's,
it's very important to have that
person to person interaction.
And the secondly,
which is very relevant to the first one,
that it's not just not the
product itself and not, no,
it's not how we deliver technology
is actually as important,
if not more than 10. The
technology itself. And, uh,
and the last one is that when
high tech meets high touch,
uh, the earlier days of
tech adoption actually is,
is it really happens at that time.
And, and, and I think that's,
that's also where the magic happens.
I think Adam and I want to sort of
kind of end in that note that um,
it's,
I'm sitting in like 2017 right now.
There are so many immense um,
sort of providence that has happened in
technology and about to come in the next
few years and we are looking at uh,
some amazing disruption can
happen in this market. Um,
you can think about,
I'm imagining these hundred thousand
health care promoters who are across the
country having access to this tool
diagnostic tool who can go house to house,
collect data,
send data to the cloud,
have AI engine looking
at it and give some, uh,
diagnostic ideas and linked them
to specialist solar on the world.
Amazing things can happen if we,
I'm thinking very focused,
customized specific product,
financial product being delivered to
various groups all around the country
because you have access to the data
because you're sitting on a huge data gold
mine. Look, understanding when
people send money, what people's,
what we'll do with the money,
you can actually come up with very,
very useful products in the coming days.
You can look at the jobs market,
informal formal book,
how you can make matches so that you can
increase the wages for the people who
don't have access to
those key information. So,
so amazing things can happen
in the coming days. I mean,
I just want to sort of think that,
you know,
if Google will all its resources,
martyr engineers that are,
you guys are all out here,
you can partner with some of the small
sophisticated distribution network that
we have at Brac.
Real magic can happen in the coming
days and real disruption can happen.
And personally speaking,
over the last few years
as I have learned to have bigger dreams,
uh,
I actually have learned to appreciate
slow innovation and a lot more than I used
to. This is a picture of
a train station and a,
particularly during the festival time,
just I love to show this picture
because in our presentation, I mean,
it's a chaotic region.
It's a chaotic country,
enormously resource constraint.